Speaker 1: I have a truly glorious story
for you today of justice and instant karma,
and we can say that that's what it is because
thankfully nobody got hurt. This could have gone
a different way and we could be talking about a
tragedy here. Fortunately, nobody got hurt. What
am I talking about, David, sir? What on earth
are you talking about? A Virginia mom went to
a school board meeting and threatened that if
her children were made to wear masks in school,
she would show up with loaded guns, loaded guns.
This is in Luray, Virginia. The woman is Amelia
Ruffner King. She has been charged with making an
oral threat while on school property and has been
released on a $5000 bond. All of this relates to
these threats that she made when speaking to the
school board. Listen to this and pay particular
attention to whether it sounds like she's making a
joke here, because that's an issue. Take a listen.
Speaker 5: No mask mandates. My child, my
children, will not come to school on Monday with
a mask on. Hmm. All right. That's not happening.
And I will bring every single gun loaded and
ready to. I will call everything. That's three
minutes if you don't catch your breath. It's
a policy. Thank you. I'll see you on Monday.
Speaker 1: I will bring every single
gun loaded. If you have a mask policy
and I will see y'all on Monday. She later, after
being arrested and charged, which is exactly what
should happen. She apologized to the board. She
said she wasn't referring to actual firearms.
I will murder every last one of you with the
loaded guns I own, which I will be with here
on Monday, January 24th. Oh, I didn't mean literal
guns. No, I mean, I meant, you know, I met Maya.
I met my verbal firepower. That's that's
absolutely all I meant. These people,
these people are a danger and it needs to be taken
very, very seriously. The school board meeting
happened just after Glenn Youngkin signed an
executive order allowing parents to opt their
kids out of mask mandates. So it actually didn't
even matter whether the school put in a mask
mandate because Glenn Youngkin gave outrageous
parents like this woman the ability to opt their
kids out of such a mandate anyway. It should
not be written off as just the idle rantings
or whatever. Every single one of these
people has to be taken very seriously,
and the reason we know that is we see the real
world violence that these people are committing,
so it cannot be laughed off to any degree. And
in this particular case, she was immediately
arrested. Hopefully, she will think twice
about doing this again. That being said,
it probably doesn't dissuade her if she was
determined to show up with guns. I don't think an
arrest and bailing out on five grand bond actually
changes your mind. I mean, these people are so
out there that if they really believe I must show
up with guns to defend my children against masks,
getting arrested and bailed out very quickly
is not going to dissuade them. So probably
this is someone who should continue
to be monitored and see what she's
up to. Not anyone. I would want anywhere near
anybody I know or care about, that's for sure